the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi our lecture today is entitled
implicit differentiation and aside from
other considerations this lecture bears
a very strong relationship to many of
the comments that we've made about
single valued functions and one-to-one
functions let's get right into the topic
by talking about one particular phase
that somehow rather we may have taken
for granted but which really is a lot
more sophisticated than we really
imagined at first glance let's look for
example at an expression such as y
equals f of X a rather harmless
expression we write it down quite
frequently and we say things like what
given that y equals f of X find dy/dx
and you see the point that we've made
here is we have assumed that Y can be
solved for explicitly in terms of X in
other words in terms of our function
machine we visualize an F machine X goes
in as the input Y comes out as the
output and everything is fine now the
interesting point is simply this let's
look at a slightly more complicated
algebraic equation for example X to the
eighth plus X to the sixth Y to the
fourth plus y to the sixth equals three
now in this particular example notice
that x and y are not given at random for
example if I say let me pick X to be 2
and Y to be 2 and I put 2 in for X and 2
in for Y just look at what happens to
the left hand side here it makes in
particular 3 a pretty big number in
other words when X is 2 and Y is 2 this
equation and we'll talk about the
meaning of an equation more in just a
few minutes but this equation does not
balance so to speak in other words while
we cannot pick X at random for a given
value of y once X is given notice that
we wind up with a six degree polynomial
equation in Y which determines at most
six values of Y
and if we're given a value of y as a
fixed number we wind up with an eighth
degree polynomial equation in X which
means that what X is no longer random
either the point is it is very very
difficult if not impossible to try to
solve this particular equation for y
explicitly in terms of X or for X
explicitly in terms of Y and the
question is how do we tackle something
along these lines and we make a very
casted assumption and by the way you'll
notice that when you read this section
in the text there are several remarks
saying that many of the proofs are
beyond the scope of the textbook at this
particular point and they'll say we'll
talk about this later and there are
references to more advanced textbooks
the point is that from a rigorous point
of view this is true however from a
geometric intuitive point of view it's
quite easy to see what's really going on
here as we shall do as the lecture
progresses but for the time being let's
review what that tacit assumption is
essentially what we say is let's assume
that Y is a particular function of X
what particular function of X is it well
it's that function of X such that when
you replace Y by that function of X this
becomes an identity and this is what I
want to talk about next you see assume
that Y is that function of X such that
when you replace Y in terms of X X to
the eighth plus X to the sixth Y to the
fourth plus y to the sixth is
identically three and notice the use of
the three lines here to indicate the
identity as opposed to the two lines to
indicate the equality now obviously
there's a more important difference than
to say that one is indicated by three
lines and the other by two let me take a
few moments to digress on a very
important topic namely the difference
between what we call an equation or
perhaps more appropriately a conditional
equality and that which we call an
absolute equality or
for example let's take a look at an
expression such as x squared equals four
you say ah these two things they're
equals
and if I do the same thing two equals I
get equals so the fellow says I think
I'll differentiate both sides of this
equality if he differentiates x squared
he gets 2x and if he differentiates four
he gets zero now notice that if you
solve the equation x squared equals four
you get one x equals -2 or two on the
other hand if you solve the equation 2x
equals 0 you get x equals 0 and there
seems to be no correlation between these
two now you see what the answer to this
thing is this x squared is not a synonym
x squared is not another way of saying
for to use the language of a new
mathematics the solution set for x
squared equals 4 is what the set of all
x such that x squared equals 4 that's
another way of saying what the set whose
only two members are two and negative
two okay in other words we cannot say
that x squared is a synonym for 4 all we
can say is given the condition if X is
either 2 or minus 2 then x squared
equals 4 otherwise this is not the case
for example if you subtract 4 from x
squared you do not get identically 0 in
other words x squared minus 4 is not
another way of saying 0 for example if I
put x equals 3 in here this says what 3
squared equals 4 which is certainly a
meaningful statement but nonetheless a
false statement you see some however an
equation is something which can be true
for certain values of your variable but
false for others on the other hand and
identity as the name may imply is
something that's true for all values of
the variable for example let's go back
to something we learned in elementary
high school algebra x squared minus 1
equals x plus 1
times X minus 1 notice I wrote this with
the three lines here it's my way of
saying that for any number X whatsoever
x squared minus 1 always names the same
number as X plus 1 times X minus 1 in
other words the solution set of this
particular equation includes all real
numbers or another way of saying it is
that if you were to subtract X plus 1
times X minus 1 from x squared minus 1
the result would be 0 independently of
what the value of x was in more
colloquial terms what we're saying is
that x squared minus 1 and X plus 1
times X minus 1 are two different ways
of saying the same thing now the beauty
of an identity versus a conditional
equality is this that if two expressions
are just two different names for the
same thing then whatever is true for one
expression will be true for the other
you see in other words if the concept is
the same but only the names are
different then certainly anything that
depends on the concept will not depend
on the particular name that's involved
well as a case in point let's suppose
now I take x squared minus 1 and I
differentiate it the result is 2 X on
the other hand if I take X plus 1 times
X minus 1 and differentiate it I get
what by use of the product rule it's the
first fact that times the derivative of
the second plus the derivative of the
first factor times the second that's
what X plus 1 plus X minus 1 and that
comes out to be 2 X in other words since
these two expressions were just two
different names for the same thing the
derivative of one of the expressions
must equal the derivative of the other
because it's still the same function
that you're differentiating and this is
what we mean when we say let's assume
that Y is that function of X that makes
the resulting equation and identity
let's look at a particularly simple
illustration and we'll do this quite
often in this course namely
whenever we want to illustrate a new
topic we will always when possible
pick an illustrious a lust rate of
example that could have been solved by a
previous method as a case in point let's
look at the identity X times y is 1 C in
other words y is that particular
function of X you see such that whenever
you replace Y by that function this
becomes an identity now if that seems
hard notice that we could turn this into
an explicit relationship just by
dividing both sides of this equation or
identity by X of course that assumes
that X is not equal to 0 but if we do
that Y becomes 1 over X now notice that
1 over X has the property that as long
as X is not 0 if you multiply that by X
you get identically 1 x times 1 over X
is 1 2 different ways of saying 1 now
how does the method of implicit
differentiation proceed we say okay
since this is an identity if I
differentiate both sides with respect to
X the derivative of the left hand side
should equal the derivative of the right
hand side now how do we differentiate x
times y observe that we're assuming that
Y is a function of X therefore x times y
is a product of two functions of X to
differentiate a product we use the
product rule namely we will take the
first factor times the derivative of the
second with respect to X that's dy/dx C
because Y is the second factor plus the
derivative of the first factor with
respect to X well the derivative of X
with respect to X is 1 okay times the
second factor which is y that's now the
derivative of the left-hand side that
must equal identically the derivative of
the right hand side the right hand side
is 1 the derivative of a constant is 0
so we wind up with the relationship that
x times dy/dx plus y must be identically
0 and now solving for dy/dx in terms of
x and y we find that the Y DX is equal
to minus y over X ok by the way notice
that by picking a
problem that could be solved explicitly
for Y in terms of X we have a very
simple check on this particular problem
namely we know that y if X is not 0 that
Y is another name for 1 over X therefore
minus y over X is another name for minus
1 over x squared but we already know
that if y equals x to the -1 by another
method we know that dy DX is minus X to
the minus 2 which is also minus 1 over x
squared and so we see that the new
method does give us the same answer as
the old method by the way let me make a
rather important aside over here and
that is when you look at something like
this you might say something like I
wonder what happens if I try to compute
dy DX say when x equals 2 and y equals 3
now you see if you mechanically plug
into something like this you'll get what
minus 3 over 2 which is minus 3 halves
the point that I want to bring out and
we'll come to this as at the conclusion
of today's lecture also is the concept
of related rates and related variables
notice that whereas from this equation
it looks as if we can let y equal 3 and
X equal 2 notice that if we go back to
our basic definition x and y are related
so that they are not independent notice
that as soon as we say let X equal 2 we
have what that 2y is 1 and y must be
one-half in other words when you use
implicit differentiation never forget
that whenever you're going to compare x
and y you must go back to the equation
or the identity which implicitly relates
X to Y well so far this may look rather
easy and straightforward but the fact
remains that there are certain
subtleties here which we have not hit
yet so what I'd like to do now is pick a
second example slightly more complicated
than this one which can still be solved
explicitly but which leads to a wrinkle
which we may not have observed
before with this in mind what I would
like to do is the following let's
consider the relation x squared plus y
squared equals 25 and ask the question
how do you find dy/dx in this particular
case again what we adieu what we do is
we assume and this is the big word here
there are lots of things that you can
assume but whether they exist or not is
another question will that's the part
that the textbook means is more advanced
and is hard to justify but let's take a
look here we'll assume that Y is a
particular function of X with the
property that when y is that function of
X x squared plus y squared is
identically 25 okay
those what it means is that whatever x
and y are they're related in such a way
that x squared plus y squared is a
synonym for 25 if we now proceed by
implicit differentiation here you see
the left hand side is a function which
is the sum of two functions of X the
derivative of the sum is the sum of the
derivatives the derivative of x squared
with respect to X is 2 X the derivative
of 2y with y squared with respect to X
is not 2 y the derivative of Y squared
with respect to Y is 2y by the chain
rule the derivative of Y squared with
respect to X is what the derivative of Y
squared with respect to Y times dy DX in
other words this is simply 1 2y dy/dx so
the derivative of the left hand side is
2x plus 2y dy DX the derivative of the
right hand side the right hand side
being a constant is 0 and if we now
solve for dy/dx in terms of x and y we
find that the Y DX is minus x over Y ok
this is all there is to this thing
mechanically by the way of course it
happens that as you probably remember
that x squared plus y squared equals 25
is a circle centered at the origin with
radius equal to 5 ok so far so good
we'll come back to this diagram in a
little while but the thing now is could
we have solved the same problem by
solving for y explicitly in terms of X
the answer in this case of course is yes
namely if X square plus y squared is 25
that says that Y squared is 25 minus x
squared and therefore the desired
function of X Y is what function of X
it's plus or minus the square root of 25
minus x squared in other words that's
what it's the positive 25 minus x
squared to the one-half power that's one
of the solutions and the other solution
is the negative 25 minus x squared to
the one-half power I simply use the
exponent notation because it's more
familiar to us in terms of
differentiation to differentiate the
exponent rather than the radical sign
but the idea is this notice now that we
begin to see a multivalued function
creeping in over here in other words we
now find that we want to solve for y
explicitly in terms of X that we do get
the problem that Y might be about a
multivalued function of X well we'll
look at that in a moment for the time
being let's simply do a double check
over here
let's actually differentiate this thing
explicitly and see what the derivative
turns out to be if we differentiate this
we bring the one-half down we replace it
to an exponent one less and by the chain
rule we must differentiate 25 minus x
squared with respect to X that's minus
2x collecting terms and simplifying we
get what minus x over 25 minus x squared
to the one half and we call it a 25
minus x squared to the one half is equal
to the Y value in this case we get to
the derivative of Y one with respect to
X is minus x over Y one just calling the
function this that in any rate shows
what the negative x coordinate over the
y coordinate and that certainly checks
with the result that we had before in a
similar way in a similar way
if we're now differentiate y2 with
respect to X bringing down the exponent
multiplying by the derivative of what's
inside with respect to X we wind up with
the same expression as we did before
only now we remember that y2 is defined
to be negative 25 minus x squared to the
one-half so this is really negative y2
by the way notice again that we get the
same answer here as we did here I like
to keep the minus sign with the
appropriate term in other words notice
that was the fact that y2 was
multivalued that caused us to have two
different possibilities here in the
first place now let's go back to our
little graph over here and take a look
to see just what happened here
remember all through this course we've
said what beware of what happens when y
equals zero notice in terms of our
picture and our related rates here when
y is zero X is not some arbitrary number
when y is zero since x squared plus y
squared equals 25 when y is zero X must
either be 5 or minus five so what's
happening is the bad point when y is
zero are the bad points are right here
and notice the rather interesting thing
here and this is what comes up more
analytically later the only time you're
in trouble when you assume that y is a
function of X remember function means
single valued is that if you happen to
be in a neighborhood are five comma zero
or minus five comma zero notice that for
any neighborhood surrounding this point
there is no way if this point here is
included there is no way of breaking up
this function to be single value in
other words if you must have a smooth
portion of the curve that includes five
comma zero as an interior point no
matter how you do it the resulting curve
is going to be multi valued and then
we're in the same predicament again in
other words from a theoretical point of
view geometrically speaking it's very
easy to assume that Y is a function of X
that makes our equation and identity but
from a real point of view what may
frequently happen is that the only type
of function that would work is what we
call a multi valued function that's
exactly what's going on over here and
that's why a textbook which is trying to
be rigorous has to be very very careful
in explaining what happens in
neighborhoods of points like this but
again we'll talk about that in more
detail in a little while
I would like to make one aside over here
you may recall that we learnt in the
last in one of our previous lectures
that by inverse functions we can
differentiate things like X to the
one-half X to the one-third this
generalizes very nicely and very simply
in terms of implicit differentiation
namely suppose you have y equals x to
the P over Q power where P and Q are
integers in other words your exponent is
now a fraction raise both sides to the Q
power and you get y to the Q equals X to
the P now we know how to differentiate
powers of X or Y if the power happens to
be an integer so by implicit
differentiation assuming that this is
now an identity which it is if y equals
x to the P over Q if we differentiate
both sides with respect to X the
derivative of the left-hand side is Q Y
to the Q minus 1 times the derivative of
Y with respect to X that is we're
differentiating with respect to X and
the derivative of the right hand side is
P X to the P minus 1 and since this is
an identity these two expressions must
be equal if we solve now for dy/dx we
obtain this expression replacing Y by X
to the P over Q and multiplying out here
and remembering that when you have an
exponent in the denominator it can come
up into the numerator by changing the
sign a little bit of arithmetic shows
that dy/dx is P over Q X to the P minus
1 minus P plus P over Q
the P and the minus P cancel out and we
find what that dy/dx is P over Q times X
to the P over Q minus 1 remembering that
P over Q was our fractional exponent we
again see what that to differentiate X
to a fractional exponent P over Q you
bring the exponent down and replace it
to by one less so that gives us an
alternative method for finding the
derivative of a fractional exponent by
namely using implicit differentiation
now the reason I put that aside in is we
could certainly get along without it but
I felt that before we go any further
that I would like at least add on the
more elementary levels to be sure that
we understand explicitly what implicit
differentiation means with this in mind
let's now go back to the problem that we
started off with in this lecture namely
the curve whose equation is X to the
eighth plus X to the sixth Y to the
fourth plus y the 6 equals Street and we
say what let's find the equation of the
line tangent to this curve at the point
1 comma 1 by the way I did something
that teachers are allowed to do here I
rigged the problem to come out rather
simply you see what I did was is by
picking 1 and 1 here
it turns out what that if I made the
right hand side just equal to the number
of terms here I would get this thing to
check out but notice by the way if I had
just picked the point at random to try
to even check whether that point is on
this curve or if it were on this curve
to find out where it intersects what is
coordinates are this is a rather
difficult problem in other words if I
just pick a random value of x as I said
before I get a six degree polynomial
equation to solve you know and if I pick
a random value of Y an eighth degree
polynomial equation to solve you know it
might be nice to pretend that the eight
was at or something like this and solve
it as a quadratic equation but quite
frankly solving polynomial equations
which are higher than degree two is a
very difficult task in fact if the
degree is greater than four it may
even being an impossible task I'm not
going to go into that now because it's
not that crucial what is crucial is to
observe that this particular problem
makes sense it's a meaningful problem it
would be difficult if not impossible to
solve for y explicitly in terms of X
here okay
yet to solve this problem we can now use
implicit differentiation except for the
fact that we can no longer check back by
another method to see if the answer is
right that's why I wanted to pick a few
introductory examples that we could
check by other means now that we have a
feeling for this maybe we will trust the
technique in a case where we have no
recourse other than to use the technique
so what we do now is this we say okay
let's assume that Y is that function of
X that differentiable function of X that
makes this particular equation and
identity and assuming now that this is
an identity let me differentiate both
sides with respect to X see this is a
sum one of the terms you know some
happens to be a product but by now
hopefully how we go about something like
this will be old hat namely to
differentiate the left hand side with
respect to X we get 1/8 X to the seventh
plus what the derivative of X to the
sixth which is 6 X to the fifth times
the second factor which is y is the
fourth plus the first factor which is X
to the sixth times the derivative of Y
of the fourth with respect to X that's 4
y cubed dy DX plus the derivative of Y
of the sixth with respect to X which is
d6 y to the fifth Y DX that must be
identically 0 and if we now solve this
for dy DX just by transposing we wind up
again with a rather messy expression but
which does show what dy DX looks like in
terms of x and y we were interested in
knowing what the slope was not for only
for any old value of x and y but rather
for what when X is 1 and Y is 1 and that
works out very nicely computationally
it's just minus 14 tenths in other words
at the point 1 comma
the slope of the curve is minus seven
fifths the curve passes through the
point 1 1 hence it's equation is y minus
1 over X minus 1 equals minus 7 fifths
or more explicitly 7x plus 5y equals 12
and the point that I wanted to make here
is notice that nothing changed in
principle from our first few lectures
notice that to find the equation of the
line we still use the recipe that we
have to know a point on the line and the
slope the only thing that's changed with
today's lesson is that we can now find
the slope of a curve at a particular
point that we could not find prior to
today's lesson all in this change is
that we have one more technique for
finding the derivative of a particular
type of function I would like to analyze
this problem in more detail in
particular I would like to see where the
numerator of this expression can be 0
and where the denominator can be 0
because you see in terms of slopes where
the numerator is 0 it means the slope
will be 0 that means we have a
horizontal tangent line where the
denominator is 0 that means the slope is
infinite ok and where the slope is
infinite that means you have a vertical
line and that means you have a vertical
tangent ok so let's take a look and see
what that means keep this particular
equation in mind because now you see on
the next board all I want to do is work
with what this thing means in other
words dy/dx would be 0 when my numerator
is 0 my numerator can be written in this
particular form by the way his again an
interesting point when will this
expression be 0 and the answer is when
either of these two factors is 0 well
the first factor is 0 when x is 0 and
the second factor is 0 since these are
even powers only when x and y are both 0
notice however that x and y cannot both
be 0 recall that the equation was what
whatever it was notice that 0 0 is not a
point which satisfies the
remember zero zero the does not satisfy
X to the eighth plus X to the sixth Y
squared plus y to the sixth equals three
it's equal to zero you see but at any
rate notice that the slope is zero only
when X is zero and because of the
particular equation when X is zero we
will go back to that in a minute
let's just check to see what's happening
here the denominator will be zero in
other words when the X dy is 0 1 over dy
DX you see only when this factor here is
zero and that occurs again
why keep in mind is this remember I put
this down here so we could refer to it
and I forgot to like put it here and
that's why I didn't see it until just
now all I'm saying here is that notice
that when X is zero Y must be this plus
or minus the sixth root of 3 and when y
is zero these two terms drop out x must
be plus or minus the 8th root of 3
coming over to a graph here then what we
see is that the curve crosses the x-axis
at this point with a vertical tangent it
crosses the y-axis at this point with a
horizontal tangent ok notice by the way
that this curve is also symmetric with
respect to both the X and the y axes
because if I replace X well it's not
important and I don't want to obscure
the lecture by taking time out from this
nap for this now but the point is a
quick check shows that this curve is
symmetric with respect to both the X and
the y axes that if I could plot this
curve just in the first quadrant the
mirror image with respect to the y-axis
would then show me the second quadrant
if I then took the mirror image of this
upper half with respect to the x axis
that would give me the lower portion of
this curve the curve tends to look
something like this and by the way all
we've done if we look back over here if
you can see this ok the 7x plus 5y
equals 12 simply turned out to be what
the equation of the line which was
tangent to this curve at this particular
point what I'd like to show you in terms
of one to oneness and single valued miss
is this that I told you I was interested
in what was happening at this curve at
the point 1 comma 1 suppose I had said
instead find the equation of the line
tangent to this curve at the point whose
x-coordinate is 1 where you see there
are two points on this curve whose
x-coordinate is 1 you see this is a
double valued curve a given value of x
between these two extremes yields the
two values of y I would have had no way
of knowing which of the two Y values I
meant you see and correspondingly if
somebody has said find the slope of the
curve or the equation of a line tangent
to the curve at the point whose
y-coordinate is 1 notice that this curve
is not one-to-one
in other words if the y-coordinate is 1
notice that I cannot distinguish between
the point 1 comma 1 and the point what
minus 1 comma 1 you see this again our
problem with inverse functions and thing
and things of this particular type if
we're told the neighborhood of the point
that we're interested in we're fine if
all we're told are one of the
coordinates and have to find the other
there is a certain amount of ambiguity
and keep in mind by the way that I
deliberately rigged this problem to get
something I could graph at least in many
cases it's much more difficult to even
visualize what the graph looks like much
more complicated you see computationally
this can become quite a mess the
important point is that what we were
doing implicitly here assumed on the
explicit fact that I could take this
curve and break it down at the two P at
the points where I have vertical
tangents and look at this as two
separate curves c1 namely the original
curve but restricted to Y and the
original curve but restricted to Y being
negative in other words I can look at c1
as being this piece
and c2 as being this piece and the again
the point is what that whenever you're
in a neighborhood of these points you're
in trouble because notice that no matter
how small a neighborhood I pick if I
can't tell one of these branches from
the other no matter how I do this I'm
going to be caught on a multivalued part
of the curve over here well at any rate
I think this begins to show us what
implicit differentiation means why we
have to be careful of points at which
vertical tangents occur but I would like
before closing this lecture to
generalize the concept of related rates
and make this a little bit more
applicable from a physical point of view
and that is when we say in something
like this that let's assume that Y is a
differentiable function of X there is no
reason to have to assume that the
variable you want to relate things to is
X itself for example let me do something
which uses the same kind of an equation
that we had before but only from a
different point of view see now instead
of asking for the slope of this circle
or what have you
let's would the question this way let's
suppose we have a particle the particle
is moving along the curve x squared plus
y squared equals 25 where the physical
reasons we'll say x and y are in feet
and that we know at the point 3 comma 4
DX DT that's what the horizontal
component of the speed of the particle
is 8 feet per second and the question is
we'd like to find dy DT the vertical
component in other words the particle is
moving along this circle we know that
the point 3 comma 4 X is increasing at
the rate of 6 feet per second while the
increasing X direction is this way so
somehow rather we know that the particle
is moving along the curve in this
direction you see if we're moving in
this direction its x-coordinate would be
decreasing not increasing and the
question that comes up is how do we find
dy DT in this case we see all we do in
this case is we say look at instead of
assuming that Y is a differentiable
function of X
why don't we assume that both x and y
differentiable functions of T in other
words let's assume that x and y are
differentiable functions of T but make
this an identity you see which make this
an identity in terms of T now again as
long as this is an identity and we're
assuming that x and y are differentiable
functions of T there is absolutely no
reason why we can't differentiate this
both sides of this equation with respect
to T instead of with respect to X if we
do that we get what 2x dx/dt plus 2y dy
DT equals 0 you see the same principle
as before even though we're now
differentiating implicitly evidently
what we could call parametric equations
we're assuming that x and y are
differentiable functions of T you see
from this identity now we can conclude
that dy DT is minus x over Y times DX DT
and now you see to polish off our
particular problem namely we're
interested in 1 when X was 3 y was 4 and
the X DT is 8 now as I find out from
this that dy DT is minus 6 feet per
second you see the idea was that X and y
as positions of the point were related
by the fact that x squared plus y
squared had to equal 25 in other words
this is what we physically call a
constraint and by the way this is what
makes calculus such an important
powerful analytical tool notice that in
doing this particular problem I never
had to know explicitly what functions x
and y were of T all I had to know is
what that x and y were differentiable
functions of T I don't care how the
particle was moving away from the point
3 comma 4 as long as x and y were
differentiable functions of T this is
how the rates dy DT and the X DT had to
be related well let me summarize what
was really important conceptually
about today's lecture the most important
thing conceptually was what with all of
our talk about explicitly writing
an output and an input in many important
mathematical relationships the variables
that we're concerned with are implicitly
related in other words we are not told
what Y looks like in terms of X but
rather how x and y are interrelated and
from here we have to find a derivative
and the way we do this is that we make
the assumption that an appropriate
identity exists that Y is an appropriate
function of X that makes the
relationship and identity the validity
of when you can do this
for example geometrically when do you
wind up not having a point that includes
a vertical tangent a point where you
can't separate the curve doubling back
that turns out to be a rather difficult
point from an analytical point of view a
point that we will return to in a more
advanced context when we deal deal with
functions of several variables but for
the time being all I want you to be left
with in this lecture is the feeling that
we can given an implicit relationship
under the proper conditions assume that
the appropriate explicit relationship
exists and that we can differentiate
both sides as an identity well enough
set for today and until next time
goodbye
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate